i actually got a chance to
pull him out we did skin to skin right
on me you helped pull your son out you
were involved in the delivery process
hold on i literally it's so crazy
[Music]
adrian i want to back it up to june yes
came over to et you and i did a
full-blown sit-down we talked about
every aspect of your life and when it
came time to chat about the whole
motherhood update you were like
everything's going really well i don't
think you can have those
conversations and talk about things
until
you feel
strong enough to and i think that's okay
to recognize what you're ready for and
what you're not and hold sacred to you
what is sacred now that we know the
secret is out was it interesting
hardest thing to do i think i was just
like bubbling and it's crazy because
afterwards when you when i talked later
we were just like i was like
stay tuned face we got you know just a
lot going on and we also also talked
about just the end of the reel and the
timing and i really felt like
it was really serendipitous in a way
like it just all was exactly the way it
was supposed to be it allows me to be a
full-time mom and it allows me to
really fulfill my greatest dream and
give 100 of myself to that so it
actually like there was all of that that
i was thinking in my head while having
um the interview with you but it was it
was so hard to keep it a secret you have
been such a a wonderful source for women
especially
you've never held anything back in your
life career personal you're like this is
what it is and here's what i'm going
through but for you to kind of take this
and make it your own and say this is off
limits i'm not telling the world was
that a conversation that the two of you
had together
it was yes
for i think because social media says
everything is immediate everything is
open to interpretation everything is
open to somebody else's i don't know if
i like his eyebrows or not whatever
we were just like let's not let's like
not do any of that we had like even
considered like not even announcing till
like thanksgiving like maybe
thanksgiving will tell people i've had a
kid
be like a six-month-old
exactly it hopefully inspires somebody
to say i don't owe this to anyone i
don't owe an explanation to anyone about
why how and i think that you know there
is that saying get out of my uterus as
women we have people constantly prying
and asking questions that sometimes are
just inappropriate in it sometimes you
don't want to share after everything
i've been through multiple miscarriages
i've done ivf
eight eight times eight cycles so i feel
like
to some extent
i owed it to myself to give myself that
privacy to give myself the right to have
something sacred that was just for us
and our family and that ultimately i
wasn't gonna disappoint anyone i wasn't
gonna disappoint my i think it's hard
enough to deal with your own
disappointment when you go through
things like this
um
that it gets that much harder when you
feel like you have to now explain to
everyone else i wanted to go through
this without anyone else's opinions but
but ours so you get you get the good
news that this is happening a baby is
coming
who do you tell how many people held on
to this secret
so crazy enough i actually found out um
on the set of ravens home bad day
backstage oh what great day great day
you know really uh really inspiring the
kids we literally implanted that week
that i was filming and then yeah for
ourselves it was for her yeah israel
then came
to the set during my lunch break and
we're like two days a day we're gonna
get the news they're gonna do the blood
test they're gonna find out if we're
pregnant so we literally sat in our car
on the set and when we got the phone
call that yes we were pregnant the first
person i called was my mother of course
after my mom was my sister after my
sister was
my mom your mom so really inner circle
real real
circle very very very very close i mean
they're they're people i think who are
still offended that we didn't tell them
then and it's it's okay i mean they love
us and it's fine you're both such strong
people of faith
and i i have to imagine that going
through a process like this
it tests your faith at times
as you hit roadblocks roadblock after
roadblock what was it that that kept you
both
in the game and feeling optimistic
for me honestly um
it was her resilience i've actually
never met anyone in my whole life
i've been on the earth five decades now
i've never met anyone in my life with
her elasticity and what i mean emotional
elasticity meaning
bad news on a monday the day is just
awful it's you could feel the tension
the the heaviness the disappointment and
then she'll wake up tuesday morning like
so babe let's go let's go let's go to
runyon let's go for a hike let's and i'm
like are you okay you know i finally
walked into our backyard i was like god
listen man like i know i've done some
terrible things in my lifetime like
please don't punish her for that like
plea and i'm like bargaining with god
and going back and forth and like
yet every prayer would sort of end with
but i trust you like i know your ways
are higher than mine and i know that you
know what you're doing i joke that's not
real i am either the most resilient
human being or the most delusional it
could go either way you know like i will
literally go through the worst thing and
then the next morning be like i have a
new baby name he would just look at me
like are you okay i have to say this
journey obviously with surrogacy is not
what i initially thought my journey to
motherhood would be like at all like i
imagined beautiful maternity photos and
what would it look like and being
pregnant and and i dreamed of that and i
still dream of that and i'm hoping that
that doesn't mean that that's not going
to happen to me for me um in the future
but
i
remember
literally telling my sister like maybe
two days after ever was born and just
being like i would not change a thing i
would not change the process i would not
change how long it i wouldn't change
anything about my journey and that's
where faith comes up even
trying to time when we would implant
around the real hiatus and be like so
i'll give birth in july and i'll be back
to work in september like
and then i i look at that now and my mom
would tell me girl stop trying to
control everything and there's so many
things that you think you're gonna think
when you're a mom and it all just
changes it goes out the window when
you're holding that baby you're like
okay i don't care that i don't have
maternity photos to show
[Music]
you guys opted for a home birth what is
a home birth experience like this was a
completely different experience and it
was absolutely beautiful my surrogate is
a rock star she's incredible she
actually this was her fifth
pregnancy her third surrogate baby
it was actually her suggestion so
literally
um my mom was there
my sister was there you were there and
literally tucked right in a room behind
us was my nieces his daughter everybody
just went so they met him within minutes
of him being born the emotions were out
of this world my sister filmed it
and when i watched it back it's actually
so cringy because you have an out of
body experience you're not thinking
about like oh what do i look like right
now so when i watched it back the things
that i was saying i literally was just
saying over and over again i love you so
much i love you so much i love you it
was but it's i actually got a chance to
pull him out we did skin to skin right
on me you helped pull your son out you
were involved in the delivery process
full on i literally it's so crazy first
you see he was born with all this hair
so that was the first thing i saw and i
was like oh my god he has so much hair
and and it's so wild
just the miracle of life is
it blows my mind i just got to see his
little face at first and the next foot
was then gonna be his little shoulders
and i got to grab him but i'm in
awe staring at this little face like i
was just like
he has a whole face like he's real
his little neck was like up and looking
around the room strong i had the
strongest little and i i literally said
i'm like um is he supposed to be doing
this he wanted to see what was going on
he was like mommy he wants to know the t
he wants to see who's here what's
happening
he was looking around it was
absolutely insane
now that ever is a month old and you've
had time to really enjoy this this month
as a family unit watching adrian become
a first-time mom describe what that's
like i hope i can say this on a family
show it's the sexiest thing i've ever
seen in my life honestly i i mean that
and and really all the sexiness started
probably top of the year because
the way she went into nesting extreme
nesting mode we need 900 of these
outfits we need
one million of these diapers this is the
best in the world i knew i was
oh my god that we were pregnant
instagram knew we were having a baby
because i got every ad for every little
one you could have had
and i bought them all for algorithm it's
all baby stuff yeah all baby stuff
you guys didn't know but instagram knew
but i listened
she is so maternal
she is so
tuned in
he loves her the way he falls asleep on
her like i take 20 pictures a day just a
bat just
of their bond and and him and i got a
nice little bomb you're going to you're
amazing i have to say like i think it
makes a cute you know you hear oh my god
it's exhausting the first month i
and and it is there's no doubt there's
moments where you're just delirious but
it's how you deal with that
deliriousness like i love that i have a
partner that we're literally in the
middle of the night looking nuts in the
dark like changing diapers into and
we're dying laughs laughing we're just
like great this is the best reason to be
delirious ever so i
i i just i can't thank god for a better
better father better husband better
partner to do this with because you're
so hands on
and just like you're just like diving
like there's mornings i'll do the night
shift and then iz will be like hey just
sleep in i'm gonna take him now you guys
revealed that you have five embryos left
so i'm i'm curious in a perfect world
what does your family planning journey
look like moving ahead all the kids
all the kids honestly that would be our
dream we're like cheaper by the dozen
absolutely my dream would be that i will
carry one day and the thing is when you
only have one embryo left you can't
test your body if it's never been proven
to carry full term
and
now that i've got five there's more
opportunities to try so that is that's
my hope
that's the goal and i've not given up on
that dream
[Music]
i feel like the knowledge of him coming
totally inspired our last project like
it like
we just i feel like we just sang
differently i feel like we just felt
differently sure i remember just singing
it differently because i'm sitting there
knowing like my baby's on his way like i
can count on
that he does make miracles happen he is
a god of miracles
[Music]
is
[Music]